there is a guy up in the San Francisco
area he is California's state legislator
Scott weiner yes his name is Weiner and
he's big on chopping off wieners uh you
can't make this stuff up here he is
honoring the drag queens from really
what is an anti-catholic hate group at
the Capitol but just look at this
so proud of uh sister Roma and her work
in the community and I'm proud of
California for standing strong
to support lgbtq people as our community
is under assault in the rest of the
country
sister Romo went on to say it's an
incredible honor to have been nominated
she says being recognized not only means
a lot to her but the lgbtq community at
large okay first off I don't know what
they mean by her is that person a woman
or a man or what
um The Sisters of the of Perpetual
Indulgence is what they go so she's not
a she's not a real sister in any way
this is not a legitimate sort of
religious group or anything like that
again nobody the G's have just nothing
to do with this it's so boring and and
ridiculous but but it's interesting they
never when they when they're going after
you know when they're mock the whole
purpose of this group really is to is to
mock Christians right it's to mock
Catholics in essence right like they're
pretending that they're like this order
of nuns
funny that they never do this with
Muslims right isn't that bizarre they
never dress up like a bunch of Muslims
in Drag and see how that goes right and
then the LA Dodgers are honoring this
group literally honoring this group we
covered that last week it's funny I
wonder if they would do that why doesn't
Scott weiner have the balls you see what
I did there to do that you guys get
exactly what's going on these people by
the grace of God they live in a largely
Christian Society because only
Christians would put up with this
sanity
[Music]